anyway I have a question for you yeah
don't you so many times your servers
block me is that true I was like and
they were like sorry Kimmy enough new
email now
yeah that's quick question yes what
should blog company was right people are
bringing contact constant tremendous
content four times a day right to
audiences boom well what else should
they be doing to prepare themselves to
be more valuable in next five years
okay I think video I think video is a
big separator I think what you know
deeper Nate niches I think that people
that are putting out content need to see
white spaces I'm so like you know if
three years ago you understood the
combination of the right white space of
where interests are going and the right
media to deploy if you three years ago
went all-in on vegan green juice yoga
lifestyle on snapchat and you never
wavered from three years ago to the day
give me a beast and so like that's what
I've done in my career right it was it
was YouTube or Twitter and then you know
there was a pocket where I wasn't
snapchatting YouTube YouTube again and
live streaming like hey but it's a white
space that you're authentic to like I
didn't go to youtube I did wine it's
what I knew I knew there was gonna be
much bigger genres than wine but I did
wine because it's what I knew so if you
if you think that green juice is gonna
be a space before you do it maybe you
document your journey of learning about
green juice right I do watches and we do
the video we do
but is there any more networking nothing
just keep it 18 months I didn't nobody
gave a [ __ ] my facebook fanpage from the
beginning of the game till three weeks
ago got me to 500,000 likes right all
this 500 in the last three weeks it's
gone from 500 to 720 because it's just
momentum people so like oh hello it's
forever it takes forever like everybody
I go over I've been doing this my whole
life like I've been putting out contents
of it to the masses for 10 years in this
market every day and I think people
don't realize what kind of consistency
and timing and then there's a moment in
time that it pops so just consistence
again and try things like musically I
think some important you start looking
for those white spaces but Facebook and
YouTube is a expandable